متابع وتطورات الابرز مع مراسله الجزيره
كارمن التي تنضم الي من دونيتك مرحبا
كارمن كان بوصله الاحداث
غيرت الوجهه قليلا والتوجهت من جديد الى
شبه جزيره القرم ماذا في تفاصيل التطورات
هناك
نعم محمد بطبيعه الحال شبه جزيره القرم
كانت نصبه اعين الاوكران منذ زمن طويل من
انضمتها روسيا عام 2014 ونذكر بان هذه
الحرب في دومبس بدات منذ عام 2014 وليس
قبل عام او ونيف من الان ولكن ما يجري في
شبه جزيره القرم مرده الى محاولات
اوكرانيه لاستعاده هذه المدينه متى بدات
هذه المحاولات تكثفت هذه المحاولات في عام
2022 نذكر جيدا انه في ابريل من العام
تم استهداف الطارات موسكفا في تلك المنطقه
والحدث المفصلي بالنسبه للتطورات
الميدانيه والعسكريه في شبه جزيره القرم
تجلى في استهداف جسر كيرتش او جسر شبه
جزيره القرم الذي يصل روسيا بشبه الجزيره
في اكتوبر من العام الماضي تتالت الهجمات
الاوكرانيه يوم امس بطبيعه الحال تحدثتم
في الخبر عن استهداف سكه الحديد احد
المسؤولين المحليين حمل اوكرانيا مسؤوليه
هذا الحادث واليوم مسيرات ارباع اربع
مسيرات تم اسقاطها في شبه جزيره القرم
لماذا هذا الاهتمام بهذه المنطقه لاسباب
عده سياسيه تحدثنا انها المنطقه الاولى
التي ضمتها روسيا اليها عام 2014 وهناك
اسباب استراتيجيه عسكريه من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه تعطي هذه المنطقه لمن يسيطر
عليها
اليد الطول في البحر الاسود وبطبيعه الحال
امتدادا الى بحر ازوف وهو ما قامت به
روسيا عبر سيطرتها على هذه المنطقه
واستخدمت روسيا شبه جزيره القرم كمنصه
لاطلاق الصواريخ والهجوم على جنوب
اوكرانيا ايضا لحصار المناطق الجنوبيه في
اوكرانيا خلال هذه الحرب من ناحيه اخرى
ايضا هي مهمه جدا من الناحيه العسكريه اذ
ان فيها قواعد عسكريه ضخمه وكبيره ومئات
قواعد العسكريه المختلفه في في شبه جزيره
القرمو بالتحديد في صفا ستوبل تاريخيا
فلنعد قليلا الى التاريخ حين يعني بعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي عادت شبه جزيره
القرم الى اوكرانيا واضطرت من بعدها روسيا
الى دفع ملايين الروبلات سنويا
لابقاء اسطولها اسطول البحر الاسود في
البحر الاسود ولكن مع اتخاذ هذا القرار
عام 2014 وضم هذا اشبه جزيره القرم
استعاده روسيا من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه الميدانيه هذه المنطقه ايضا هذه
المنطقه كانت احدى اللاءات بالنسبه لروسيا
في التفاوض وفي عمليه التفاوض التي بدات
والتي تم الحديث عنها بالاحرى بوساطه
تركيه كانت احدى اللاءات الاساسيه بالنسبه
لروسيا شبه جزيره القرم ومصير شبه شبه
جزيره القرم نهائي ومحسوم هذا امر اتى على
لسان كل القيادات الروسيه من الرئيس
الروسي وصولا الى وزير الخارجيه المتحدث
شكرا على كل هذه التفاصيل كنت معنا من
دونيتسكو ونقلت لنا تطورات الاوضاع فيما
يتعلق بشبه جزيره في القرد تحديدا